hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of wtr aka
what's that for you this is where we
look at TV shows that may be forgotten
by some but remembered by others for
just how strange they were but that's it
have you ever wondered what the worst
sitcom of all time is I love your
probably King ideas in your head already
like the Geico caveman show or that Rob
Schneider comedy remember home boys in
outer space and how about normal Ohio
the show where John Goodman was gay and
that was the only joke I don't even get
it if you look at a la Liz
somebody shows around there some of them
aren't but the one that is always
guaranteed to be on there somewhere is a
little lady sitcom simply known as small
wonder what's the movie a I too funny
for you well this'll fix that right up
it's a sitcom about a father who invents
a robotic girl named Vicki
despite her doing oh I don't know
everything to prove that she's a robotic
girl nobody seems to catch on they don't
even question why she talks like a robot
or why she looks like one half of the
shining girls gotta sting your unless
you're out of luck Jamie's spending the
weekend with this friend Reggie now of
course anybody in this situation would
think holy shit this man has created
artificial intelligence and can change
the world what's he gonna do keep it
secret of course because that's just
what people in the eighties did got an
alien keep it a secret made a woman keep
it a secret
got a child doctor all know you can
exploit that all you want but is he gay
yep there's absolutely no reason
whatsoever to keep her secret or really
even to have her around it's only to
serve the insanity of the plot and trust
me there was plenty of that to go around
but that's not to say the nosy neighbors
ever didn't notice it's just though they
can never quite catch them at the right
moment to prove it but that of course
doesn't stop their daughter Harriet who
I swear is just
an older version of pistol to keep
hitting on their son Jamie my father got
a new job Harriette he's gonna make me
go oh he can't we never get married
Marty pick out the dress because hey who
cares if they made the greatest
scientific discovery of everything ever
known everywhere doesn't mean you can't
totally ignore it and get some smoochies
hi Jamie
I hear it so with such a ridiculous and
even kind of frightening scenario you
think this show would barely even make a
season now just to give you an idea here
how many seasons do Veronica Mars have
three how many seasons did Firefly have
one how many seasons did small wonder
have what the fuck was this show really
so good that we needed at least four
years of it under our belt well remember
this is at a time when pretty much any
family sitcom idea was watched by
somebody but then again for years I did
shit what how how can I accept that
while still believing in humanity well I
have a theory it's bad yes but it does
manage to get a few laughs Kamiya let's
look at the most obviously funny thing
about the whole entire show its tone
this is drenched in 86 Comp cheese just
look at this opening it's a masterpiece
of SAP
she's a small wonder lovely and bright
and soft words she's a small
a child like you get all the jokes based
around bad green screens and opening
like this would suggest but with this
child-friendly tone comes moments that
clearly don't fit in with it for example
there's an episode where the kids take
up smoking he does all the typical
cliches you'd see in most non-smoking
episodes but then it ends on this note
remember I told you about Peter Watson
oh yeah that big smart jock who gave you
the chewing tobacco well he got this
sore in his mouth I found out it's
cancer Oh No
Christ Oh Jamie I'm really sorry well
y'all never smoke or chew again yeah
after that shit we need to say our
finishing line with an applauding
audience while somebody shrugs to a free
frame ha ha child is dying of cancer
it's small wonder there's other things
that clearly wouldn't fly in today's
more PC world that just sound really
funny coming out of a child-friendly ad
show awesome you said it so did you
three weeks ago and Reggie showed you a
Playboy magazine yeah you heard right
Playboy they didn't make up a name or
called adult books or anything
they named a specific porno magazine you
can buy anywhere get them started while
they're young I guess there's also a
scene where Vicki starts reading one of
the neighbors romance novels character
facia
into a strong mesoderm and crushed her
to his heaving chest
oh that's just weird the bizarre astiz
when the parents are deciding whether or
not to make love while Vicki is sleeping
in the cupboard
yeah it's pretty fucking out there
what's the problem it's Vicki yet I
think she can see us
don't be ridiculous no she can't seems
like this are just so awkward it's
surprisingly hard not really to laugh at
them Vicki wet the floor okay she hasn't
even wet the bed yet
hey guys how you doing Vicky I haven't
even wet the bed yet what can you say to
that
somewhere between Shou friendly fluff
and enjoyably uncomfortable a joke like
that just can't find a home that's part
of what makes it so fascinating cuz
there's a lot of scenes like that I do
you like it Joanie I mean would you
rather have a redhead I don't know is
this adorable or scary as shit it's one
of those rare sitcoms that's just so
hard to get a grasp on is it smarter
than looks like third Rock from the Sun
or just accidentally getting a laugh
like full house nobody could really
figure it out
whenever you get a painful groaner like
this with the data pads hooked into a
self-organizing systolic array processor
that makes them you suddenly get a kind
of funny moment like this
happy anniversary from Jamie and me and
to give this to you one of my favorites
has got to be when she enters the talent
competition there's a legitimately funny
scenes when they're trying to defeat
their neighbor's kid in a competition
and clearly use her programming to cheat
after this obviously tell this kid
performs vicki goes up playing the piano
at a slightly unrealistic level
that's funny enough but then they top it
with this
look on their face sums up the show what
the hell can you even say while looking
at it but that's still not the end the
final topper comes when they find out
that the kid with the least Talent is
the person who won we'd like to
congratulate Ellen sue on a victory and
also congratulate her parents who happen
to be the owners of this beautiful
shopping mall also are the judges that's
actually kind of legitimately funny I'm
sorry it's a clever buildup delivery and
payoff so yeah for as corny as it all
seemed there did seem to be a fair
amount of effort that was thrown in for
a while there was a point when even
small wonder jumped the shark
it was around season four when any sense
of effort stopped and they just threw
whatever shit came out of their asses
like there's an episode where Vicki's
evil twin yeah that dumbass thing wants
to be a star while visiting Hollywood so
she likes her family in a studio set
dungeon who would put a functioning lock
in his studio set dungeon and how is
that the biggest thing that bothers me
but by far the greatest fail in the
show's history comes down to one simple
joke it's when a Russian built a robotic
boy named good enough to go up against
Vicky and a test of intelligence when
the father discovers this by looking him
over he calls him out on it
kid happen to be a cybernetic and you
say a shot sneakin you couldn't leave
good enough alone have you ever heard a
studio audience reject the joke they
were given I mean that wasn't like
laughing politely you're not laughing at
all leaving abyss island that was verbal
disgust they usually just double F track
over it or edit it out so it sounds like
not that many people were laughing but
no they left this in for some reason
like even they knew this was
embarrassing to put out there and they
just didn't care you couldn't leave good
enough alone oh that was the audience
for small wonder saying you know what we
deserve better than this
and seeing how we already set the bar so
low for you to begin with that's saying
a lot
needless to say this was the last season
that ran and if I was just going by that
season maybe I would have seen why
people would call it one of the worst
sitcoms ever but with all the stuff that
came before it I have to say I don't
think it's deserving of that title it's
bad but it feels like it had fun with
how bad it was
when I think of the worst shows ever I
think of ones that are boring or
insulting or it could have been so much
more this one started off so clearly
with nowhere to go with that by its own
low standards it kind of acquitted
itself I can't say it's a graveyard of
humor and creativity it's a little too
weird for that it just stood out too
much to be placed in that category
it wasn't mean or selfish either they
even pushed some good organizations like
the Ronald McDonald House I mean clearly
its heart was always in the right place
maybe that's why people still remember
it it stands out because you can't
figure out where it's supposed to be
placed it's clearly not smart but it's
not totally stupid either it's not for
adults but it's not always for kids it's
not funny the way it should be but that
doesn't mean it's not necessarily funny
it's a strange concoction that seems to
have no real label
it's confused on what it is just as much
as we're confused on what it is but
that's just what makes it all the more
fascinating it's one of the most awkward
sitcoms because you just don't know how
to react to it or how where the creators
are and that can make for entertainment
that's hard to classify but nevertheless
entertainment one that'll delight your
funny bone and haunt your nightmares for
many years to come
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and sleep well